tu n'es plus seul et tu m'as bloc et tu
penses que j'ai une autre à mes côtés
toi tu t'es fait une raison sur un coup
de tête et ça me tourne autour akwasi
côté mais je les envoie balader
elles n'ont pas ton sourire je leur ai
dit sort et depuis je suis parti ton
coeur et balafon je passe mon temps à
sortir tu te bats domestos on a plus
rien eu sur dumas ou j'ai fait et je
vois tu fais ta vie que dans le futur
prix mais je te connais par coeur pour
ça c'est pas de côté
mais que tu crois que je suis d'ailleurs
j'ai comblé le vide dans les bras d'une
et moi je crois que des bailleurs dans
ses bras on s'est moqué
manqué
[Musique]
manger
marqueurs
[Musique]
le 7 août
mon coeur est solitaire et le tien et
d'ailleurs de penser manquer
l'impression de mentir quand on se
souhaite le meilleur sans dire un mot
on s'est tourné le dos com deux inconnus
quand on se croit dans band aux plus
favorisés suis pas parano tu me
surveille sans cesse me souvenais poteau
et on t'oubliera
le temps nous dira si on a bien fait
désistement parfois si je fais semblant
sais que j'ai ma fierté
tu crois que je suis naïve que j'ai
comblé le vide dans les bras du nord
et moi je crois que des avancées ont
cimenté manquer
mon père ans
manqué
manquerait environ
c'est
ça va moi je fais jamais
je sais quand il me rappelait chaque
envie que je vienne
qu'est-ce qu'on veut ou cvt on s'oublie
on se voile en souffre et ne se cachent
qu'est ce qu'on fait on s'appelle pour
de bon ce biais au revoir on s'est
montrés
[Musique]
ok
manqué
marquer
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]